Heat. Heat.
[Music]
My background um uh ethnically uh my
family is from Egypt. Uh Coptic
Christians, the native inhabitants of
Egypt. Um and uh they immigrated here. I
was born in the United States. They came
here a few years before I was born. So I
grew up bilingually. I could speak
Arabic um at least after a fashion the
Egyptian dialect. I later on I also
studied in college formerly Arabic and
English and I always had an interest in
this the nexus of essentially Christian
civilization and where it meets Islam as
as you can imagine because of my own
background. So even in history I majored
in um even in college sorry I majored in
history and it was basically the near
east the middle east the mid and the
medieval era as well um and my first uh
my master's thesis was about the first
military encounter between Muslims and
Christians the battle of the armuk in
the year 636. So obviously I've been
very interested in it for a very long
time well over 20 years I've been
involved in this field. I also uh went
ended up going to Georgetown University
for a little while and and at while I
was in Washington DC, I worked at the
Library of Congress um as a language
specialist for the Middle Eastern
division where I had access to so many
uh wonderful books, including those
written by al-Qaeda, which leads up to
my first book, which was the al-Qaeda
reader. I discovered writings by
al-Qaeda back then in 2005, 20 years
ago. And um uh since then I've just uh I
later on in around 2009 I resigned and I
basically have been a fellow at various
think tanks just writing constantly um
including books about again these very
same topics. Um, one of the main topics
being the persecution of Christians
under Islam, but I've also gravitated
back towards my historical interest, my
my sort of academic interest from way
back. And that's the books that you're
seeing now, basically, Sword and Scitar
and Defenders of the West, where I'm
essentially picking up where I left off
at my master's thesis, which was the
first battle of Yamuk. Now I'm like
basically I've been fleshing it all out
all the centuries that followed
thereafter all the conflicts and the
battles and the various personages and
etc. And um you know I'm involved in
this field in other ways as well. I give
frequent talks you know internationally
and I've testified before Congress. I'm
involved in lawsuits that deal with
Islam and radical Islam etc. Yeah. So
there it is. Just very quickly you
mentioned Coptic Christianity. There's a
term you don't often hear. Uh when we
talk about Coptic Christianity, what are
we talking about?
Well, yeah. That's why when I mention
this um usually in in in public
settings, the next thing I say is don't
ask me which precinct I work for because
Coptic, most people think I'm saying I'm
a cop. Uh yeah, the word Coptic, the
word Coptic, of course, it just it
basically it's it has a very interesting
province and I'm glad you asked. Um it
just means so the word for Egypt or
Egyptian the English word comes from the
Greek word as many words do from those
times. So the Greek word is agitos meant
Egypt or Egyptian. So when the Arab
conquerors conquered uh Egypt in the 7th
century they basically I don't know
maybe they were a little lazy they just
took the middle of the three syllables I
giptos they took gipped and gipped
became coped. That's how it reached us
finally and it just meant a native
Egyptian who was by nature Christian. So
today when you say cop you mean an
Egyptian who's Christian. So even in the
word itself it just it it underscores
how to be an Egyptian meant to be a
Christian back then during the first the
Muslim conquest. As a people they're of
course uh you know they're the again the
ind indigenous Christians of Egypt. They
account for it depends on who you ask
the numbers are very hard to get but
something like 10 to 15% of the
population which is now largely Muslim
but at one time of course they were the
overwhelming majority in the 7th century
and they are regularly being persecuted
as uh you know as comes out very often
not in the mainstream media of course
but uh this like I said this is one of
the fields or topics I follow very
closely one of my books is called
crucified again exposing Islam's new war
on Christians came out in 2013 And so,
yeah, I've been following what happens
to the cops and other Christians all
throughout the Islamic world in the
Middle East, in Africa and Asia and so
forth. And they're all experiencing the
same sorts of discrimination at the very
least and persecution in places like
Nigeria outright genocide. When we talk
about Islam and Muslims, what are we
talking about? Is there an overlap with
the terms? Do they mean the same thing?
Yeah. So again with the words uh Islam
one of the big lies that we got and you
know as all good lies are it has some
truth in it but we were told back when
Islam became popular in 2001 that um or
notorious that Islam means peace okay
and while it doesn't Islam means
submission but yes the word Islam and
the word peace are etmologically
connected in Arabic is very interesting
it's you know you get three consonants
and out of those three consonants you
depending Depending on where you put the
vowels, you can make all sorts of many
different words that are somehow
connected. So, Islam means submit. Salam
means peace. And the logic is when you
submit to Islam, then you have peace.
And a Muslim uh we pronounce a Muslim,
but a Muslim is one who submits, right?
And so to be a Muslim, you know,
interestingly, it didn't again
westerners and Christians um they
project their own sorts of religious uh
you know uh religious understanding on
other religions. So they don't I don't
think they understand that the word
Muslim itself what it meant originally
was basically uh acknowledging the
political authority of Muhammad and his
successors who supposedly represent
Allah. So to be a Muslim had nothing to
do with the condition of your heart, you
know, uh how how your relationship with
God. It was literally submission to your
political rule. Yours being the Muslim
leader at the time, Muhammad and his
successors. Would you mind taking me
back a little bit? Sure. Sure. Yeah,
that's that's my forte. So basically
Islam uh you know, the main thing is uh
it gets exciting. So Muhammad, you know,
the traditional story is he's born 570
and he goes, "You're one of
Yeah, of course he Oh, are you privy to
that little conversation that I've been
engaged
in?" Yeah. Yeah. I firmly believe a
Muhammad figure existed. Uh the the
weight of evidence is overwhelming from
his from if you know how history is
done. Yeah. There's a guy that what
maybe his name wasn't Muhammad. Maybe
that was a title. That's all nitpicking,
but there was a a prophet who arose in
Arabia who basically promised paradise
to his followers and he came with the
sword. Okay? I mean, that's that's clear
enough because that's widely attested by
non-Muslims who lived at his time. At
any rate, as far as the long heaphical
story that Islamic tradition
encapsulates, yeah, of course, there's
probably a lot of holes in that um etc.
But anyway, so and then what I'm giving
you is the barebone facts. So we don't
even have to go into the secondary sort
the the vast questionable stuff.
Muhammad preaches, you know, his
religion, which is submission to Allah.
Long story short, six by 632 he dies and
now all of Arabia has been consolidated
under all these waring tribes are now
part of the Muslims. They're they're
under the umbrella of Islam. They're the
submitters who submit to Allah. uh for a
couple of years. Some of them try to
break away. There's the apostasy wars.
Then they're all brought back and by 63
uh4 now they basically are all really
unified and they spread out and what
history knows as the great Arab
conquests begin. Okay. Um and long story
short, so from the year of Muhammad's
death, 632, if you fast forward to 732,
one century, Muslims conquer all of
North Africa. They conquer all of the
Middle East and they enter into Spain
and in 732 I give you that year because
that's where they're stopped finally in
the middle of France at the battle of
Poier or or Tours. Um and what most
people don't realize is all those lands
that I mentioned. Okay, so greater Syria
at the time which encompassed Lebanon,
Israel, Palestinian territories, Jordan,
a large portion of Iraq, of course, Asia
Minor, um, Egypt, all the way to, you
know, Morocco, Libya, Tunisia, Algeria,
all of those were not just Christian,
they were more Christian than Europe.
That was the heart of Christianity was
that area in the 7th century when Islam
conquered. Yeah. And uh you know so many
people have sort of this fact has been
hidden from them. They just think
somehow those countries were always
somehow Muslim or or somehow like that.
No, they weren't. That's why Constantine
the Great, the Roman emperor moved the
capital from Rome to the east because
that's where everything was. You know,
you had five major centers, five seas.
Only one was in the west, Rome, and the
other four, Antioch, Alexandria,
Jerusalem, and later Constantinople were
in the east. and all four have been
conquered. Uh so actually if you look at
a map, Islam essentially conquered and
annexed and tore away threearters of
what was once Christendom. Um and you
know history now just remembers
Christryendom as Europe as if that was
always the case. It wasn't. It was a
much larger um organic uh um
civilization which was all centered
around the Mediterranean. That's why it
was called a Roman lake. uh and uh you
know from Egypt to Rome that was a very
simple thing or Syria by travel but it
was all broken us under and actually we
can get into it but that's what led to
the dark ages or at least what
historians used to call the dark ages
because now you had little Europe which
was this kind of the little brother the
little Christian brother big brother has
been taken away and he has all the
resources all the knowledge and now
little brother's on his own and this is
when the like I said the dark age begins
and you literacies lost. Papyrus is uh
gone because all the all all written
records in Europe were coming from
Papyrus in Egypt. And all that's just
one example. There's one historian um
Henry Pin, a French historian who
actually has a a very interesting thesis
which is what I'm basing what I'm
telling you on. Um and his book is
called Muhammad and Charlemagne or
Charlemagne and Muhammad. And his whole
point is you could not have Charlemagne.
You could not have the rise of the
Frankish Empire. All that without Islam
because it's Islam, Islamic forces
attacking Europe and creating this
discontinuity with the east is what led
directly to the rise of Charlemagne and
the Frankish Empire which of course led
to the rise of Western civilization as
we know it. And so if you read some
historians and I quote some in my books,
uh, Franco Cardini, I think he basically
says Islam was an a violent midwife to
Europe. Uh, it really gave birth. That's
how he characterizes. And I think that's
a pretty pretty applicable um, app propo
characterization. So anyway, these
attacks go on and like I said, so much
has been conquered and taken away from
Christendom and then they resume again.
Uh, and the Mediterranean islands are
all conquered eventually. you know,
places like Sicily and Malta had Muslim
Muslim uh presence for centuries, roads
and Cyprus and all these places. Spain,
Spain had Islam in it for about 7800
years. Okay, that's the whole reconista.
So, you have the hold up Christians
after it got conquered in 7-Eleven and
they slow they're living in caves in the
northwestern quadrants of the peninsula
and they start slowly century after
century fighting back until around 1492.
and and Muslims are still there longer.
But then you have the rise of the Turks
which was an even more traumatic uh
impact on the Christian world. They
eventually become the new
standardbearers of Islam and jihad. They
take to it in ways that the Arabs never
did. Um and they essentially take over
from the Arabs. So for a while you have
the Turks who are actually sultans. That
means they're the the rulers. But they
keep the khalif in in the abbassid khif
in Baghdad. they keep him as a
figurehead for, you know, basically
until the Mongols stomp him to death
with their horses rolled up in carpets,
I think in
1258. Um, so but the Seljixs, they now
renew the jihad and they they take over
uh or the Turks, they take over Asia
Minor. And Asia Minor, again, like I
said, was one of the oldest Christian
territories. This is where St. Paul
sends his letters, many of his epistles,
and it's now Turkey, right? Um and you
again if you what's good about that or
not good but we have a lot of um
relevant sources because the closer you
come to our time we have more reliable
sources with numbers as opposed to the
7th century it's really shrouded in mist
but when you look at the you know around
the 11th century when the Turks are
taking over Asia Minor you have
chronicles that talk about literally
tens and hundreds of thousands of
Christians Armenians Syrians Greeks
being butchered massacred enslaved
thousands of churches being desecrated
burned torched, crosses being broken.
Um, so the religious hostility is there.
Okay? You know, you know ISIS, the
Islamic State, and how what they do,
what they say, and then we're told that
has nothing to do with Islam. So what
I'm telling you from the beginning, it's
all been there. Okay? All that stuff.
Even worse, ISIS on steroids basically
is what I'm describing for centuries.
Um, and that's by basically now we're in
the year 107. 1071's a major battle. The
battle of Manzer, the Muslims, the Turks
win. They defeat the Eastern Roman
Empire and now they're right in front of
Constantinople right across the street.
And this gives rise to the first crusade
uh which was called for in 1095. And um
I just find it amusing because if you
talk to someone about the history or the
history of conflict between Muslims and
Christians or Muslims and Europeans,
it'll start in their mind it starts with
the first crusade. And that's by design.
That's very intentional. A very famous
quote. Yeah. Exactly. So, and there's a
very famous quote from a professor,
Georgetown professor who I knew, John
Espazito, and I've quoted it so many
times that I think I can do it verbatim
now, but if not, it's very, it's
paraphrase, but he writes, "Literally,
five centuries of peaceful go
coexistence elapsed between Christians
and Muslims until an imperial papal
power play called for a series of
so-called holy wars against Muslims,
causing centuries of of distrust and
resentment. from Muslims to Christians.
So he's saying that before the first
crusade in 1095, everything was peace
amongst Muslims and Christians. But look
what I just told you. Muslims literally
carved out three quarters they conquered
3/4 75% of what was Christian world and
constant persecution. You know one one
of the my favorite examples is just in
one year in the year 1009. Okay, so a
little over a century less than a
century for the first crusade. You have
one khalif, a fatimid khalif centered in
Egypt who according to Muslim sources
destroyed 30,000 churches in Egypt and
Syria which on the one hand emphasizes
what I'm saying which is that area was
very Christian in the early centuries
when Islam conquered it and it also
emphasizes the persecution. Okay,
30,000. That's a that's a hefty number
including the most important church or
basilica or cathedral in Christrysendom.
The Haga Sophia which was built uh at
top the resurrection site of Christ in
Jerusalem. All right, that too was
destroyed and raised. So uh and yet
according to my and here's the big
confusion. Most modern historians are
pedalling this idea that everything was
fine until the first crusade that there
was no reason for the first crusade.
that it was just a bunch of imperial
papal power play like I said and and and
would be colonizers and just adventurers
who decided to go to the Middle East for
no reason and just start killing Muslims
and since then Muslims have been upset
at Christians and it's just the complete
opposite. Even if you look at what Pope
Urban II said uh to rile up the
crusaders or the emperor, Emperor
Alexius, the Roman emperor who sent
letters asking for help, it's exactly
what I said and even more graphic. All
it does is talk about what the Turks and
the Muslims were doing to Christians.
The persecution, the rape, the like
sadistic abuse and torture, disembowing
boys and and women and raping them on
altars and pouring their blood in the
baptismal font, etc. Yeah. Really,
really bad stuff. Um, so that I'll stop
right there. You wanted a quick tour for
Yeah. Yeah. So, so, okay.
So what was the goal the the game plan
then of Islam? It seems just aggression
and annihilation of
Christianity. Yeah, you can say that the
goal the open goal of Islam which comes
out in the Quran, it's in the hadith.
It's codified by the Islamic scholars
known as the is that Islam must it's
it's its destiny is to rule the world.
And what that and that is done by jihad
which is arms struggle. And um you know
one of the mistakes is some people used
to say that Islam's goal is to convert
every last soul. No, you don't have to
convert to Islam. Um but it has to have
political authority over the entire
globe. And then you you have three
choices. You as a non-Muslim can embrace
it and become a Muslim and now you have
all the same rights that Muslims have.
Or you can pay jiza which is tribute.
And this goes back to Quran 9:29. means
you pay money and you also embrace a
host of discriminatory
um lifestyle measures. You can't build
churches, you can't fix churches. If a
Muslim comes and wants your seat, you
have to give them the seat. Um you're
you know two Christians testimony is
equal to one Muslims testimony in the
court of law. You know, obvious
discrimination. So you have to embrace
and accept that if you want to keep your
religion and pay a special tax on top of
everything else you'll be paying. um and
and also endure sporadic persecution
that rises now and then which still goes
on all throughout the Islamic world or
you reject payment of tribute and you
fight. Okay. So let's say in the Middle
East and those regions that I discussed
that got conquered in the 7th century.
So the Christians there is is eventually
opted to pay the tribute and live as
secondass uh citizens. In Europe they
didn't and they fought back. uh well in
Spain they also got conquered in certain
areas but by and large Europe took the
third option which is um fight okay and
that's what it was so so yeah I mean the
death and destruction is part and parcel
of the jihad but it's its goal is
essentially uh again just world hegemony
so so far historically Islam and
Christianity
uh have not been compatible
well no uh
And that's the irony because um again
one of the big lies is we get all these
so-called ecumenicists or you know who
try to tell especially Christians who
try to tell us that oh Islam you know
it's it's such a brother religion and we
have so much in common and people like
Pope Francis for example is very famous
for doing this and the game they play
again is they'll say look you know
Muslims uh believe in Jesus and they do
uh in in Islamic teaching Jesus was born
of a virgin and he's perfect and he
performed miracles. Okay. Um but the
problem is they don't of course which is
all good but the problem is what what
Muslims do is they appropriate the
religious figures of Jews and Christians
but then they recast them in a way to
validate themselves Muslims and demonize
Jews and Christians. Okay. So for
example um you know the when it comes to
Jesus, Muslims don't believe in the most
important things. They don't believe he
was crucified. They don't believe he was
resurrected. They don't believe he died
for the sins of man. They don't believe
he's the son of God. So that's much more
important from a Christian doctrinal
point of view than what they do believe.
And that creates conflict because that's
actually taught in the Quran. And in
fact, the reason Christians are bad is
because they say Jesus is a son of God
and that's why they must be fought. So
obviously that is more problematic than
saying they believe that Jesus was born
of a virgin. So their Jesus is really
not the Christian Jesus. Even the names
are different. Asa is his name. Okay.
But I'll give you another better
example. So for example, um a lot of the
uh the people who claim that there's a
lot of commonalities, it's called the
Abrahamic religion. So they say that
Judaism, Christianity, and Islam are
brother religions. Okay? And the reason
they call him Abrahamic is because all
three sort of find trace their roots to
Abraham. Okay? So now in now we know
let's say the Genesis account of
Abraham, we know what he you know he God
calls him forth and he goes to you know
the promise try to find the promised
land etc.
But in the Muslim account, it's the same
thing. But then uh Abraham tells his
former people, his formal formal former
kin blood relatives and tribe how
there's nothing going to be nothing
exists between them from now on but
hatred and enmity and war because they
don't believe in Allah. Okay. Well,
that's not in the in the Bible. Okay. So
that was added and that gives Muslims uh
you know the the impetus to hate and war
on Christians and Jews and everyone
else. So they take so they take Abraham
because and they want to the reason they
appropriate all the biblical figures is
because Islam is the new kid on the
block. It's the newest religion and it's
trying to associate itself with these
figures of antiquity which all religious
people believe in. Okay. Um but then
they use it for themselves to you know
make uh to make the Christians and the
Muslims. So when Jesus comes back for
example Isa uh on resurrection day which
sounds good sounds Christian the first
thing he's going to do is break all the
crosses cancel the Jiza and kill all the
pigs. Okay. And uh he's breaking the
crosses because he's finally fed up with
these crazy Christians thinking that he
was crucified. Uh and he's and he's
cancelelling Jiza means no longer can
you be a Christian or a Jew and pay
tribute. Now you either have to be a
Muslim or die. Okay? And well, yeah,
killing some swine because Islam just
hates it, you know, just to keep it all
together there. So you see what I mean?
It's like so to me this is I always give
this analogy um of imagine someone who
says uh hey I I know your grandfather
and he was my grandfather and you know
that sounds on on the surface sounds oh
we're related but then he tells you and
everything your grandfather said was
wrong what you think he said I know what
he said and it's the exact opposite of
what you thought and then you find out
everything that your grandpa supposedly
said was not what you thought he said.
So to me that doesn't build bridges.
That's an appropriation of a people's
heritage and uh and then twisting it in
a way to actually attack them with it.
The crusade the Christian aspect was a
defense against the attacks. Is that
correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Um again because they show
the crusades in a vacuum. They don't
tell you what was happening. They don't
tell you that the Middle East was
Christian. um they don't tell you that
the Muslims were persecuting the
Christians there and elsewhere. So it
just all you know is you just see a body
of Europeans leaving Europe and going to
the Middle East and killing and fighting
Muslims there. So on the very you know
on the surface it's very obvious this is
offensive warfare uh and these people
are invading Muslim territories but they
knew and especially their their you know
the the the religious authorities of
Europe understood that all that area was
once Christian that all that area still
has all the Christian holy sites holy
sites were very important to preodern
men okay and that Christians were being
killed and slaughtered so it was a just
war in their mind it was defensive.
Sure. Sure. On the surface they were
traveling there, but again that was
under for example King Louie uh St.
Louis in his crusade uh because most of
it was centered in Egypt and there's one
point in the texts and they talk about
how when this country is brought back to
Christ okay so it's very clear they
understood that Egypt was a Christian
nation it was part of the you know it
was part of Christendom. So by it was
definitely you know a just not just a
just war it was a holy war essentially
this was a you know a thing that God
wanted at least from the context of the
time. Um but yeah now again everything
is done to make it look like it was a
complete offensive war that had nothing
to do with uh you know what we're
talking about. A Muslim is an adherent
of Islam and Christianom and
Christianity are the same thing. Is that
correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. A Muslim like I said
is a follower of Islam. one who submits
to the religion of submission and
Christendom is it's it's it's a later
made word and it just meant you know the
Christian body politic basically as if
you can think of Christianity as an
empire you know its own all the lands
that are connected together um which
again historically after the the Muslim
conquest meant Europe so to say
christryendom was essentially synonymous
with Europe but um I'm one of those
who's advocating the idea that no
Christendom was for centuries much much
larger and it was uh mostly in the
Middle East or what we call the Middle
East and North Africa uh because that
was the main Christian region.
Sometimes some people even use the word
Islam dumb as a sort of correlary to
Christendom meaning the same idea but uh
you know yeah that's an older is it
accurate to say therefore
that Christianity and the west are
synonymous.
Yeah. Well sure the west you know the
west I always find it interesting
because if you look at civilizations
today they're known by names. So you
have the Hindu civilization, you have
the Buddhist civilization, you have the
Muslim civilization and then you have
the West and it's only known by
direction and I think that's uh also by
design. So we live in a direction.
Everyone else lives in a substantive
civilization that centers around a
religion, but we're a direction. Um and
there's two interesting aspects to this.
one is I believe that's by design and
it's sort of um it was spearheaded by
the secular mentality of the west
because they don't want to you know they
don't want any connection to
Christianity so they just call it the
west we're west from you know everyone
else okay um the other interesting thing
is you know what became the west was
also again all that was left over after
these major Islamic conquests so if you
look if you think of you know the large
map which includes all of Europe but
also all of North Africa and all the
Middle East and and all that gets
swallowed up. Well, what you have left
is the West. So, the West, that term was
used even in in preodern times. It goes
all the way back to the Greeks. Um, and
but it was it was sort of because that's
the area that, you know, is still
different from that area. And most of
the East has its own kind of uh sort of
almost monolithic mentality. even the
pre- pagan in the pagan times uh with
the coming of Islam some people will say
it's very similar to it because it's
just a sort of you know almost like a
tyrannical sort of god who's whatever um
so yeah so we live in the west everyone
else lives in a civilization and um but
also the west is accurate in that the
west is the westernmost region of
christryendom that was never conquered
and that actually kind of spread out
from it later
Well, just adding to that uh and and and
also dovetailing with the um all the
incursions and the conflict um uh
chronology when you talk about
um Islamic incursions or Islamic
attacks, you you're not talking about an
ethnicity. You're talking about the
majority of a particular region
following that belief. Is that is that
correct?
Yeah. And that's a good point because
most historians for example when they
talk let's say they talk about the
conquests of whatever you know they'll
talk about Arabs then they'll talk about
Berbers entering into Spain and then
they'll talk about Turks and various
iterations of Turks. There's the Seljixs
uh the most famous are the Seljics and
then certainly the Ottomans later. Okay.
And then they'll talk about the Mongols
who are known in the sources as Tatars.
Um and all these groups had wars with
Europeans and wars with others. And so
if you read it from a national point of
view, it just seems like okay, just one
tribe fighting another. Um, but what I
find interesting is they all those
groups that I mentioned were all
Islamic. Okay. And when you really delve
into the primary sources, especially the
Muslim ones, the actual chronicles
written by those peoples, the Islamic
impetus is there. In other words, all of
them make at one point or another some
kind of reference to to the point that
we're attacking the Europeans or the
Christians because they're infidels and
because Islamic law requires it and we
destroyed their churches which is a good
thing and we enslave them because you
know Allah promises us slaves and it's
okay and you know so it all that's what
I'm trying to say. If you look at it
they're all different nationalities and
historically that's what academics do
and that's why you never hear about
Islam. you just hear, okay, there was
this one group, uh, Tamarlane, you know,
Timur the lame, uh, who's probably the
most savage warlord of history who
created, you know, pyramids of skulls.
You'll never hear that he was Muslim,
but he was. And according to his
chronicers, a lot of what he was doing
was jihad. Okay? And so that's how
Muslims understand it. So that's why I
try to bring it out uh to show that yeah
they have their national identity which
is true and they have their own peculiar
characteristics and idiosyncrasies but
the Islam impetus is always there right
beneath the level and it's documented.
Um I forget now which book I think it
might be is it crucified again you you
point out terms like let me try
attempt I hope I'm saying it correctly
which means license to lie if I remember
correctly but not just that there are a
bunch of these terms that they use uh to
justify very bad behavior.
Yeah. Yeah. Tea is one of them. And it's
amazing the amount of deception that
Islam allows. Islam is very much the
religion of the end justifies the means.
Okay? So if the end
is the the subjugation of the world to
Allah's law, which sounds good from a
Muslim point of view, the means to get
there can be very flexible. Okay? And
they do include lying. So for example,
jihad historically has meant armed
struggle. All right? But the word itself
means I always find it interesting
because people will tell you that uh uh
the apologists for Islam will tell you
that you know you shouldn't translate
jihad to holy war because it just means
struggle. And they're right but that
makes it worse. And uh I'll explain. So
the reason orientalists and earlier
people translated jihad into holy war
makes sense because in the premodern era
to struggle for Islam meant warfare
against non-Muslims. That's it. Okay.
But now in the modern era when that's
not really possible because the Islamic
world is actually much weaker. Bear in
mind that the period that I'm talking
about from the premodern era till the se
you know 7th century until let's say
1516 1700 Islam was the powerhouse not
Europe. They were the weak horse. They
were the ones that were expected to be
conquered any moment now. They were the
impoverished ones. All right. So that's
why jihad was just warfare. Now that
Islam is essentially weak compared to
the w compared to the world. Okay.
financially, economically, militarily.
Um, jihad struggle continues, but it
takes on different guises. So even
according to Islam's you know the sh or
the or the classified different forms of
jihad and I'll translate I'm translating
them in my head but basically jihad of
the tongue jihad of the pen jihad of
money jihad of the womb and what all
these mean basically jihad of the tongue
and jihad of the pen are basically
license to lie propaganda anything you
as a Muslim can do to help uh help Islam
whatever its image or to weaken and
demoralize the infidel Okay, you do it
through your pen, through your tongue.
Jihad of the money means you're you're a
rich uh oil tycoon, Saudi or, you know,
Arab, Gulf Emirate type person. Um, you
you just you spend millions and millions
to support the real jihadists. You fund
them, you sponsor them. Uh, jihad of the
womb, this is one of the most popular
one, also known as the baby jihad, is
just the idea of procreating and and and
literally outreeding the infidel. And
that's happening in Europe. They
actually say that that you have mosque
clerics telling men and the and the
women to have as many babies as possible
so we can outreed them. And it's working
all throughout Western Europe in some of
the major cities. I think London and uh
you you you know several Oslo and Norway
the number one name is Muhammad. I mean
that's amazing. That's very telling,
right? Um so you you so you have all
that and um so you have these different
manifestations and the tea like you
mentioned that's again one that's so
well Muhammad himself who's supposed to
be in Islam this perfect figure
justified lying in three cases. So any
Muslim will tell you and they are you
can lie to your wife uh to you know to
make her happy about something. You can
lie to two quarreling parties in order
to reconcile them somehow. And you can
lie in war. Of course war is deception.
All right. And uh but he's also in on
record saying if I give my oath but
something better comes along I'll anull
my oath. Um okay. So a lot of license
there's clerics out there who talk about
another even more problematic doctrine
than tea. It's called Torea. And what
this means is it's perfectly okay in
Islam if I give you sort of a a
halftruth. So let's say you need to
borrow some money and you say, "Hey, can
I borrow, you know, $10?" And I tell
you, "I don't have a penny in my pocket,
but I have $10." I haven't lied even
though you think I'm saying I have no
money.
I literally don't have a penny, but I do
have $10. Okay? But by saying I don't
have a penny and getting you to believe
that I have no money is legitimate in
Islam. Okay. So, uh yeah, these are all
the things that not many people are
aware of.
But now you mentioned uh the immigration
issue in Europe. Um it it seems like an
unstoppable train.
Yeah. You know, yes and no. I suppose uh
Europe Europe's
forebears the the ones before them who
actually fought tooth and nail to keep
Islam out managed to do it. The reason
it's it's unstoppable and a lot of
people again they miss they miss it.
It's not the Muslims in this case. It's
not the Muslims fault. Okay. Muslims are
always trying to come with their swords
and spears conquer historically. In this
case it's the European leaders who are
allowing this 100%. You can't blame the
Muslims. Muslims want a better life. And
a lot of them are not jihadists. A lot
of them are migrants. They just want a
better life. I get it. Um, so that's why
millions and millions of them are going,
but they're not getting in there by
force. They're getting in there by these
European leaders who are doing
everything to bring them in and to
support them. So really, that's the main
issue that people need to be aware of in
this case.
Sorry. Why are the European leaders
doing that?
Well, that now that's a good question.
You know, I don't know. Is this just
political correctness run a muk? Is this
they're trying to show how tolerant and
wonderful they are? or is it a little
more nefarious? I think the latter. I
think there's an agenda obviously
involved maybe in the early stages 15 20
years ago, 25 years ago. But when you
see how bad it goes and how how horrible
it's getting and all these areas that
have large Muslim migrant populations
have become essentially almost war zones
and you know regular European people are
being attacked and it's crimeridden and
rape and grooming gangs etc. you should
have stopped it. But they're actually
they seem to have accelerated it. So
obviously there's some nefarious agenda.
Some people say globalization trying to
just mix all the people together. Maybe
it's another maybe it's the way for the
secularists to destroy Christianity. Uh
because a lot of times where you bring a
lot of Muslims, the first thing that
happens is Christians have to suppress
their holidays because they don't want
to offend the Muslims. Okay? So
Christmas for example has to be
suppressed etc etc. So that too I'm sure
uh figures amongst these elitist
thinking. Yeah, that's an interesting
comment. U there was a talk that you did
uh which I I listened to where you spoke
about political correctness. People are
too scared to to say what you're saying.
Yeah. Yeah. They've been conditioned.
They've been conditioned. They're too
scared. They don't want to say the wrong
thing. And it's even worse. I mean one
the political correctness is one thing.
You know better but you don't speak it.
But I think people have just been so uh
indoctrinated that data can't even see
reality anymore that it just doesn't
even make sense. I suppose that's what
you would call wokeism. You know, it's a
severe case of extreme political
correctness where you actually believe
the nonsense. Um but yeah, it's like I
from what I'm learning or seeing England
has become just amazing. It's kind of
like you can't even speak anymore. I
think if you if you declare yourself an
Englishman and proud of England and you
wave the St. George flag, you might get
arrested, okay? But if you go around
with a Hamas flag and you know that's
fine and the police protect you, um if
you point out that there's grooming
gangs and there's certain people behind
it, you know, oh, you might get
arrested. So that's it's this is you
know you know this is a what is it?
Orson well 1984 type thing but real
extreme form versions of it where who'd
have thought we'd get to this point or a
country like England which was once a
bastion of free speech right um it was
okay to have free speech when it was all
about cursing Christ and you know
urinating in the crucifix but now and
it's Islam everything just changed full
circle um so it becomes obvious that
there's definitely an agenda involved
that there always has been you don't
hate you don't hate Islam
I don't know. I don't like Islam, but
I'm fine with Muslims. And I make a
distinction between them. Islam is a
body of teachings. It's an ideology.
Okay. Muslims, you know, there's what
1.7 billion of them. And they find
themselves associated with this ideology
for any number of reasons. Most of them
simply because they were born into it.
I'm not going to hate someone for that.
And most of them don't even know,
honestly, a lot of them don't know what
I'm talking about. They just know the
bare minimum, which is the five pillars
of Islam, okay? You know, prayer,
fasting, and pilgrimage, etc. Um and a
lot of them are very good people. I
don't so I don't hate Muslims but I am
talking about the dangers of Islam
itself as an ideology and those who
align themselves and follow it closely
which in modern parlance is radicals or
fundamentalists right um but to me it's
actually real Muslims real Muslims. Uh
so again there's many many m the the
Muslims that we call moderate are really
just secular Muslims right it's there is
no moderate Islam there's no you know
there's this good Islam and a bad Islam
there's just Islam what I've been
telling you is standard Islam that's why
when I say for example uh ISIS and all
the stuff that they did which was
horrific and everyone told us and
everyone believed that has nothing to do
with Islam but if you look at the his
historical record as I've been saying
and as in my books especially sword and
scimitar, you're going to see that
Muslims have been acting that way from
the very beginning. In fact, a lot of
what ISIS says and does is patterned
after Muslims of history. Um, famously,
they would say something like, "We've
tasted American blood and none is
sweeter." Okay, which sounds kind of
just gross and sensationalist, but that
actually comes from one of the very
earliest jihadists or mujahids who was
at the battle of Yarmmuk, which I I told
you about my thesis, and he said, "We've
tasted Roman blood and none tastes
sweeter." So, they're copying him. Also,
you know, the famous uh where they
decapitate people in orange jumpsuits,
21 Coptic Christians uh and and many
others that's actually choreographed and
closely patterned after what Saladin did
to the Knights of the Temple in the
hospital after the Battle of Hatton in
1187, for example, because it's
described in detail and it's exactly how
ISIS does it. Um so, so basically the
long and short of it is Islam is what it
is and it's a violent force. Muslims,
like I said, could be, you know,
whatever they can do. There's Muslims
who say, "Look, I don't believe in what
you're saying, and I believe Islam means
peace." Good for them. I'm not saying
they're liars, but that's for them.
They're not impacting anyone else.
That's them, and that's fine. Um, but
you, you know, there's no mosques that
really do that. Certainly not in the
Islamic world. And I'll leave you with a
final analogy. Maybe uh you've you've
heard it, but I always do it. It's the
Nazi paradigm. So, the whole world is
fine saying Nazism is a is an evil
ideology. it's racist, it's, you know,
white supremacist,
whatever. But we also know that there
were men and women who were Nazis, but
they were good people. The main one
being Oscar Schindler, right? He was a
formal ranking Nazi member who went out
of his way to help Jews and other
undesirabs from being killed. Right?
Now, how do we understand that? Okay,
was he following a moderate form of Nazi
Nazism? No one says that. Everyone says,
"Yeah, he was part of Nazism is evil,
but this guy did something good and he
rose above that thing because he's a
good man." So that's how I submit to
you. I see Muslims in Islam. Islam is a
body of teachings that is violent and
inherently intolerant to the non-Muslim.
But there are Muslims who do good
things. They they they're there. They
exist. I know. But they're doing it not
because they follow a moderate form of
Islam, just like there's no moderate
form of Nazism. They just do it because
they rise above those teachings and
they're good people. Um, so yeah. So I
don't hate Muslims, but I am wary of
Islam. But then is is Christianity's
Achilles heel being too tolerant and
forgiving?
No, I would say it's it's Achilles heel
is not that it is inherently tolerant
and forgiving, but rather we're living
in a day and age where everyone
Christian and non-Christian is
convincing Christians that that is what
Christianity is. But it's not because
historically it was much more robust. It
was balanced. Yeah, you have turning the
other cheek. You have forgiveness. But
you have a whip of cords and you have
tables being overturned in righteous
indignation. Okay? and you have laws and
you have rules and you have just war
theory which which predates it goes all
the way back to Augustine but it
arguably goes to Christ and John the
Baptist because that's who Augustine
points to you know when when the
centurion came to Christ and asked for
um for him to heal his servant and Jesus
did what does Jesus always do after he
performs a miracle he tells that person
to repent right do this do that to this
centurion he didn't tell him that if
anything all he had was praise why
didn't he tell
quit the military. You're in charge of a
brutal Roman, you know, you're a
centurion in charge of these hundred men
and all you do is kill people. He didn't
say that because it was understood that
you could you laws exist and physical
violence and force is part of enforcing
laws. So, no Christian had a problem
with that. I would say to you though
that now in recent times it's been so
emasculated intentionally to weaken
Christians. Uh, and a lot of the ones
who are doing this are non-Christians
who will pay Christian organizations to
sponsor this idea that to be a Christian
is to be a doormat. Because of course,
that's great. If I'm a non-Christian,
I'll love that kind of Christianity. If
you as a Christian think your entire
religion revolves around turning the
other cheek and forgiving me and helping
me, by all means, even if I hate
Christianity, be a Christian and spread
it because that's the best thing out
there. But historically, that's not how
it was. It was very much balanced. These
crusaders were who went and went to war,
they were Christians, okay? And they
knew in fact they would cite the the
loving your fellow man as reason to go
to war because Jesus said the two
greatest commandments, love your God and
love your fellow man, right? And they
would cite that we love our God. That's
why we're going to uh liberate the holy
land because I said like I said, holy
places are important and we love our
fellow Christians. So we're going to go
help alleviate their burdens at the
hands of these Muslims. So yeah, I would
argue that Christianity is not
inherently passive, but it has been
turned into that and for a reason. I
know that you are pressed for time. So
if if you come in for a landing with a
final message, what would that be?
Well, since we're talking about Islam,
it's just simply to for people to, you
know, wake up. Uh too often what happens
in the world is there's this incremental
thing where, you know, I I like to talk
about the boiling frog analogy. Um, and
for whoever doesn't know it, it's the
idea that if you put a if you throw a
frog in a boiling water, he jumps out
because he feels it. But if you put him
in warm in cold water and slowly warm it
till it boils, he sits in it until he
dies. And I think in many ways that's
actually that is is uh reflective of
what's happening to Western civilization
because if you look every decade, it
just gets worse and worse and worse and
none of the stuff that is uh that for
example, let's look at the transgender,
you know, all that
insanity. If you I I was watching a
video back in the 60s where they're
warning against homosexuality. Okay,
teachers are threatening students about
you better watch out from these
homosexuals. And in California, I
couldn't believe it. And I'm thinking,
imagine in that climate if you said,
"Hey, there's a million genders and I'm
a she, he's a he," you know, you would
have been laughed out. No one would have
done it. But what they did is it
happened incrementally. First they um
they normalized regular homosexuality
and you know then it was all over the
media and it was in the sitcoms and they
became very sympathetic figures and all
they wanted to do. You see what I'm
saying? But then generation after
generation until we get to where we're
at until where it's supposed to be some
great victory that our President Trump
signed in a law. That's not a victory,
man. That's an embarrassment. Okay. for
the chief uh you know the the the chief
of the United States to spend his time
uh putting a law that every child
already knows. Okay. But it just shows
you how bad we've gotten. And I think
the same thing is happening with Islam.
Um it's just it's spiraling. It's
getting out of hand. It's gotten to the
why why is a place like Europe, you
know, Europeans and white people are
about 4% of the population of the world.
Why is it only them that have to give up
their land and give up their heritage
and their culture and their religion to
to appease everyone else? It's just it's
mindboggling when you think of it like
that. But if it happens gener, you know,
slowly and incrementally, you just get
used to it. And I think that's where
most people are. So they need to sort of
rise above it and kind of objectively
see what's happening in the world. Just
quickly, you mentioned the the frog in
the boiling water. Do you know anybody
who's ever actually tested that?
No. And every time I look it up, there's
someone who's saying, you know, it's not
true. It doesn't happen if you do it.
And nobody wants true either. Yeah. No,
I haven't I haven't. I'm just using it
as an analogy. I don't want the human
rights group. So, yeah. Nobody wants to
be that guy. No, I don't want to be that
guy. But I'm sure there's been a lot of
those guys, so they must have been
tested. Raymond, uh, how can I follow
your work? Uh, thanks, Jeremy. Uh the
easiest place is go to my website
raymond Ibrahim.com and it has all my
articles and it has uh links to my books
on Amazon, Defenders of the West, Sword
and Scitar, etc. and all my videos and
my fledgling small YouTube channel where
I occasionally make little videos. If
you enjoyed this, please visit germ
warfare.com.
[Music]